salut en septembre 2020 j'ai fait ici
même un gros sujet sur ce qu était
l'échec la réussite en faisant appel au
parcours de plusieurs intervenants dans
ce deuxième épisode
j'avais envie que nous parlions ensemble
de la passion pas le fruit de la passion
pas la passion amoureuse mais bien la
préférence pour une activité le penchant
pour quelque chose
l'appétence dans un domaine le kiffe
mais la passion qu est ce que c est ce
qu on doit déjà obligatoirement en avoir
une
j'ai pas eu l'idée d'explorer ce thème
tout seul j'ai pu voir récemment le film
sol qui abordent des sujets très mature
d'ailleurs pour un film d'animation
ce qui donne un double niveau de lecture
pour les adultes et des enfants quand on
le regarde le thème principal est
central c'est évidemment la passion au
travers de joy gartner je vous laisse le
plaisir de regarder ces quelques
secondes d'extraits vous allez vite
comprendre
[Musique]
la musique et axa qui compte pour moi et
je me réveille le matin que je sors de
moulins je ne pense qu'à ça
tu réduis à l'ol sur des serait plus
c'est quoi cet endroit
c'est le grand qu'avant je crois que
j'ai rien à faire ici manoel la musique
c'est la vie
célébrée
il faut savoir écouter les bonheurs de
la vie soit prêt ta vie va commencer
sol des studios disney pixar mais qu'est
ce qui t'arrive tableau c'est pourquoi
quand disney m'a proposé de rendre
hommage à l'introspection de jo et de 22
en proposant ce deuxième épisode en
axant la thématique sur la passion
j'étais plus que ravis vous avez compris
le rêve ultime de jo c'est de jouer dans
un club il est profondément passionné
par la musique et de cette passion sont
nés des rêves
le rêve de revivre le rêve d'en jouer
dans des lieux très spécifiques et pour
tout ça il va devoir comprendre en
profondeur sa propre passion
pourquoi les nez pourquoi elle existe
comment elle s'intègre dans sa vie et
quels sont les sacrifices aussi qu'il
est prêt à faire en gros quel obstacle
il est prêt à surmonter pour sa passion
le film sol est disponible depuis le 25
décembre en streaming exclusivement sur
dix n'est plus vous trouverez le lien
dans la description vous allez adorer
maintenant nous allons découvrir comment
la passion s'ancre dans notre cerveau
nous allons aussi parler avec des
personnes que vous connaissez très bien
bernard werber à des auteurs français
les plus lus dans le monde pierre cros
qui réalise des vidéos de divertissement
depuis des années benjamin verrecchia
qui réalise des vidéos d'humour mais
aussi de cuisine lola du bini présent
dans beaucoup de domaines avec la
musique comme socle commun pas de voix
off de nombreux films séries jeux vidéos
dessins animés publicité et nat ou qui a
créé un univers allant de la vidéo au
livre en passant par les jeux de société
vous les connaissez pour une activité
qui me semble être leur passions
visibles mais est ce que c'est vraiment
leur passion profonde comment vivent-ils
leur passion au quotidien comment les
antilles découverte d'ailleurs est ce
qu'on peut se lasser une passion vous
voyez que rapidement ce thème est bien
plus complexe qu'il n'y paraît et c'est
ce que j'ai découvert en discutant avec
eux alors si vous cherchez votre passion
dans la vie ou si vous vous demandez
comment vous devriez gérer celle que
vous savez déjà
cette vidéo devrait vous vous passionnez
je m'appelle fabien olicard j'ai
toujours agi par passion du mentalisme
ou du moins c'est ce que je crois
quand on pense au mot passion on a tout
de suite la vision d'un acte
matérialiser en général d'un sport où
quelque chose de ludique voire de
créatif mais si je réfléchis ma propre
passion pour le cerveau je me dis est ce
qu'il aurait pu s'exprimer par autre
chose que le mentalisme la définition de
passion selon le dictionnaire larousse
est la suivante mouvement affectif très
vif qui s'empare de quelqu'un en lui
faisant prendre parti violemment pour ou
contre quelque chose ou encore penchant
vif et persistants comme si on pouvait
pas lutter contre ce désir de quelque
chose de quelqu'un pourtant j'ai
vraiment l'impression que chacun définit
la passion selon le filtre de sa propre
vie la passion c'est l'amour c'est
l'amour de quelqu'un de quelque chose
d'un voilà une curiosité qui devient un
coup de foudre l'amour alors qu'une
passion c'est une activité dont tu peux
pas te passer tu as envie de la faire si
tu ne la fait pas ça te démange et peu
importe le temps que ça va te prendre
peu importe le temps que tu va investir
dedans c'est pas un problème au moment
où j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos j'ai
senti que j'adorais écrire créer un film
est tourné des vidéos raconter des
histoires en fait pour moi la passion à
les relier à la notion de joie j'ai de
la joie quand je fabrique des mondes
j'ai eu de la joie quand jacques ont des
histoires chez de la joie quand j'en
écoute qui vous font rêver
une passion au sens commun selon moi
c'est quelque chose qui dans notre
ventre et qui nous fait vivre encore
plus intensément notre vie quand tu
passes du temps sur quelque chose et tu
considères que sur d'autres sujets ce
serait du temps compliqués à passer et
la passion du coup ça devient travaillé
avec passion c'est à dire que tu te
rends pas compte que tu passes du temps
à ça et que ton temps passe très vite
peu importe la ferrari tu veux peu
importe le château que tu veux et a tout
à fait le droit de ne vouloir quiquet
quel va être le moteur de sa de ta fusée
tu peux faire tout ce que tu veux
s'il n'y a pas d'essence pour faire
décoller l'histoire ça tu peux rien
faire on peut le prendre en essence 2
pour preuve les dents le ferrari mais
dans les sens quel est mon essence on
sent à travers ses réponses que la
passion organiserait une sorte de
déséquilibre émotionnel psychologique
par modification nos perceptions déjà
comme le temps qui ne compte plus quand
on est dans sa passion ou par la
naissance d'une sorte d'obsession alors
on reconnaît une passion réelle par le
fait qu'à nous obsède la vraie passion
je pense que c'est l'obsession dans le
bon sens du terme c'est à dire ceux le
joueur de guitare il va être je pense
obsédé par une mélodie par son envie de
réussir une gamme
voilà de jouer un tel morceau à la
perfection et donc c'est une obsession
du bienfait lui bien faire un pain je
pense qu'il est obsédé
il est passionné par le par ses couleurs
par leur rendu qui veut sur un tableau
mais c'est pas une option pour quoi que
est-ce que c'est oui ça peut être une
obsession qui peut le détruire au 6 mai
mais quand elle est passionnée je pense
qu'elle est plutôt positive
ta passion c'est un exhausteur de tous
les sentiments qui qui puissent exister
sur cette planète dire quand je chante
je peux être en colère quand le chant et
j'ai le droit
quand je chante je peux être hyper ému
quand je chante je peux être sensuelle
quand le champion soit il ya plein
d'émotions et tu peux passer par toutes
les émotions quand on ne connaît par ta
passion c'est une carte d'identité
différentes qui complète la personne que
tu es dans la vie c'est vraiment pour
moi deux choses indissociables moi si tu
me connais moi il faudra que tu me
connaissent un moment par ma passion
parce que ça voudrait dire qu'on se
connaît pas à 100% je trouve que la
vraie passion pour le coup c'est quand
tu en parles avec des gens et que tu te
rends compte que tu défends pas ce sujet
là comme tu défends d'autres sujets
partir en outre dit là je suis en train
vraiment de de parler avec le coeur et
je peux en parler pendant des heures et
j'ai des vrais arguments et j'ai des
vrais j'ai des vraies convictions par
rapport à ça
là tu touches au point sensible d'une
passion moi je peux parler plein de
sujets mais j'ai aidé en jeu c'est les
les 5 10 sujets où je vais en parler et
je vais pas j'ai pas prendre à la légère
j'en parlais avec des arguments avec une
façon de penser la passion est donc
identifié par des émotions fortes liées
à un sujet c'est intéressant car on
constate que ça globalise bien plus que
le simple plaisir de faire une activité
parler de cette activité ou de ce sujet
n'est alors jamais anodin on peut y voir
quand même beaucoup de similitudes avec
l'amour car dans tous ces cas le cerveau
va produire de la dopamine qui provoque
l'euphorie et de l'adrénaline et de la
noradrénaline qui peuvent provoquer des
insomnies
mais honnêtement ma passion pour le
mentalisme ne m'empêche pas vraiment de
dormir mais peut provoquer c'est vrai
des états de floride ailleurs je me
lasse pas de ce sujet alors est ce que
c'est vraiment une grande passion ma
grande passion dans le but de comparer
j'ai demandé à mes invités de me parler
de leur passion et du moment où il pense
qu'elle s'est déclenchée chez eux
comment elle a pu naître d'un tous les
plus grands plaisir que j'ai eu dans la
vie auront été issues soit du fait
d'écouter des histoires soit du fait de
fabriquer des mondes dans lequel j'ai pu
moi-même construire des histoires ma
passion n'est pas exactement les voix
c'est peut-être d'essayer d'être le plus
conscient possible dans ce que je fais
ça c'est hyper important chez moi c'est
à dire instant après instant qu est ce
que je suis en train de penser qu est ce
que je suis en train de recevoir qu'est
ce que sont en train de mettre dans mes
émotions les dents et dans ma dynamique
de créativité et évidemment ça passe par
les voies mais
pas seulement c'est à partir de ça ou
avec le filtre des voix que je vais
plutôt aussi de d'essayer d'aller dans
la réalisation peut-être de l'être
humain qu'on est soi même et en tout cas
moi c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
et franchement je suis très très très
passionnée de ça j'ai toujours aimé la
musique et moi la musique c'est ce qui
maintenant j'ai 27 ans qui a 27 ans me
fait vivre à 100 % toutes les émotions
rassemblés ont fait qu en fait un jour
j'ai senti que je chantais un peu
différemment des autres en cours de
musique et ça a été quand quelqu'un
d'autre ma identifié comme ça c'est pas
normal ce qui se passe chez elle esther
mon prof de musique qui a convoqué mes
parents disant la voix de l'eau la gelée
jamais entendu et ça fait 20 ans que je
suis prof
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose à faire
et je me suis dit mais moi je vous le
disais tout seul mais franchement je
n'osais pas me sentir un peu spéciale
puisque en soit avoir une passion ce
aussi sentir spéciale est le vrai vrai
vrai déclic mois en mois qui m'a montré
que la musique c'était viscérale c'est
que j'arrivais à chanter les chansons
des autres
j'ai compris que j'ai compris que ma
passion prenait vie en moi quand je me
suis dit que même les mots des autres
pouvaient mal et pour exprimer un
sentiment est que je ne pouvais pas le
parler en fait j'étais obligé de le
chanter
j'ai l'impression quand je regarde un
peu à travers tout ce que j'ai fait sur
les dix dernières années ou plus j'ai
l'impression que ça a toujours été ma
seule vraie passion commune à tout ça a
été de créer à chaque fois que je vais
aller dans un domaine je sais de détail
original de de casser un peu les codes
de les apprendre et ensuite de les aider
structurés moi je pense que je suis
passionné par le fait de raconter des
histoires je peux passer beaucoup de
temps à écrire un scénario avec des amis
on se réunit on prend du temps c'est
assez professionnel du coup parce que
c'est quand même des heures de réunion
mais en fait j'ai du mal justement à
dire que mon métier ce que je fais
actuellement
c'est un vrai travail parce que c'est
depuis dix ans ça reste une passion
avant tout donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
aussi cette phase où a ensuite on va
filmer c'est pas toujours évident en
vrai quand à des heures de tournage
c'est de prendre un temps fou il ya des
problèmes techniques enfin il ya plein
de choses qui peuvent agacer qui se
déroule pas comme prévu
mais tu t'accroches tu lâches pas enfin
tu lâches pas jette pas l'épongé parce
que tu veux aller au bout de ton projet
je suis passionné jeu passionné
d'histoire
par exemple je suis passionné de deux
bouts je suis passionné des gens j'adore
les gens condé je me nourris de
biographies compte qu'on me raconte la
guerre de troie ou qu'un type man
raconte ses vacances en islande
je suis voilà ce je suis passionné alors
après il ya la différence entre
passionnés experts aussi on croit
souvent que la passion à la mène
forcément la connaissance ultime de son
sujet alors qu en fait pas du tout ça
peut être je suis passionné j'ai encore
dix mille choses à apprendre mais quand
je me retrouve dans ce que je fais en
fait quand je suis moi même et quand je
suis en aligner sur ce que je fais est
sûre sur mon sujet sur la passion du
truc c'est pour ça que j'ai quand je
suis passionné d'histoire
ça veut pas dire que je vais manger 18
bouquin sur jules césar
ça veut juste dire que dès qu'il ya un
sujet sur ben je crois que le césar
c'est un exemple sur la rome antique ou
sur la grèce antique
ça va forcément m'intéressait j'ai en
fait je en train d'essayer de faire la
différence entre je suis intéressé chez
curieux et je suis passionné de benjamin
bien de mettre le doigt sur quelque
chose de primordial
la frontière est très faible entre ce
qui nous intéresse ce qui nous rend
curieux et ce qui nous passionne
la différence c'est la charge et la
puissance de nos émotions comme nous
l'avons entendu tout à l'heure mais
quelque chose m'interpelle si la
définition de chacun du mot passion
était un peu vague
très subjective je suis surpris
qu'aucune de ces personnes n'arrivent à
décrire leurs propres passions en une
phrase hyper simple et hyper clair et
pourtant moi aussi je serais incapable
de le faire
on reviendra sur ce point dans la
troisième partie qui cache des choses
vraiment fascinante pour le moment je
reste sur mes invités et je les crois
tous passionnés et je les ai invités
pour ça et pour leur pertinence mais est
ce que on peut vraiment vivre sans
passion
c'est vrai qu'il existe une sorte de
pression sociale qui nous oblige à avoir
une passion comme si on n'était pas
entièrement défini si on ne savait pas
exprimer ce qui nous plaît le plus dans
la vie et cette pression elle peut être
directe par exemple des parents qui
veulent que leurs enfants fassent
absolument une activité ou indirectes
comme par exemple si on se sent un peu
un peu nul un peu à l'écart parce qu'on
voit les autres s'épanouir dans une
activité alors que nous on a pas quelque
chose qui nous fait vraiment vibrer mais
est-ce que c'est simplement sociétale ou
est ce que c'est vraiment un problème
majeur de ne pas avoir de passion dans
cette part de quoi j'ai une de mes
soeurs qui me dit souvent j'ai pas de
passion et qui m'envient sait qui est
dans envieuse de ma passion sauf que
s'il ya des gens qui sont dans cette
situation et qui regarde la vidéo il
faut enfin je dis pas que c'est la bonne
manière de faire mais j'aimerais que
vous puissiez vous dire que ce qui va me
faire du bien à moi ne vous fera pas de
bien à vous et du coup ne soyez pas
envieux de quelque chose qui vous apaise
qui ne vous apaisera pas ne cherchez pas
la passion des gens chercher ce qui vous
passionne vous très profondément
et il n'y a pas de passion honteuse
c'est à dire que si c'est la philatélie
et les timbres qui vous apaise et chivu
stabilise ce n'est pas une honte il n'y
a pas de passion pour y il ya que
quelque chose qui répond à un besoin
vital
les écouter vous y laissez vous aller
sincèrement devenir passionnés quelque
chose c'est d'être conscient qu'on est
passionné de quelque chose les gens qui
disent je n'ai aucune passion dans la
vie et la tête la passion de rien [ __ ]
en fait on est tous passionnés de
quelque chose qu'est ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui aurait pas de passion si
on peut partager ça je pense que c'est
pas possible de vivre sans passion pour
découvrir des mondes vous devez sortir
du port
ces douaniers des rivages s'éloigner des
gens qu'on aime parfois et être sûr sur
cette mer où cet océan de la vie avec un
gouvernail et dévoile et vous pouvez pas
contrôler cet océan c'est impossible
c'est impossible de contrôler océans par
contre vous pouvez vous laisser aller
dans la tempête et il se peut que vous
mourriez mais si vous n'êtes pas parti
du port
pouvait pas découvrir votre amérique
comme christophe colomb je pense qu'à
plein de personnes qui n'ont pas
forcément de passion et c'est pas grave
c'est qu'il ya des gens qui après une
dure journée de boulot sont très heureux
juste de se poser de regarder un film
partager des moments avec leurs familles
et c'est pas très grave il faut de tout
après je pense que si personne n'avait
de passion eh ben on vivrait dans un
monde où il y aurait forcément un peu
moins d'arrêt y aurait moins de peinture
moins de deux théâtres moins de chansons
enfin est-ce qu'une passion aussi c'est
vraiment une activité artistique ou
passionnés d'automobile ou d'un truc
matériel ça se trouve aussi tu peux être
passionné juste part des gens tu peux
être passionné par ta famille et la
communication et j'ai des amis je ne
comprends pas comment ils font ils
peuvent vraiment écouté pendant des
heures et aimer résoudre des problèmes
quand quelqu'un te dis je rêve pas c'est
juste qu'il n'en a pas conscience et on
est obligé de rêver le rêve fait partie
du dollar fonctionnement du cerveau
c'est juste que healy porte pas
forcément d'intérêt il se réveille pas
en essayant d'y repenser et c'est donc
un rêve tu l'oubliés quelques heures
dans la journée voire même quelques
minutes donc et la passion c'est
peut-être ça aussi c'est ce côté je me
rends pas compte qu'en fait je passe
beaucoup de temps à faire ça et je
considère pas que ça ça peut être une
passion pour quelqu'un donc quand on
demandait ce que c'est une passion je
vais pas dire je suis passionné personne
parce que c'est c'est nul entre
guillemets mais au final pour lui c'est
une passion c'est pas plus mal ce que je
disais au début s'il considère que ce
temps c'est pas du temps de perdu ou pas
le temps laborieux bas au final c'est
une passion c'est quelque chose qui lui
fait passer du temps les ans sans s'en
rendre compte
alors j'aime pas le mot passion parce
que ça devienne pathos qui est la
douleur ser donnaient pathétique je
préférerais le moins enthousiaste
est ce qu'une vie sans enthousiasme vaut
la peine d'être vécue voilà une bonne
question
passion quand j'entends ce mot là je
pense à ces gens
passionnément amoureux donc on sait déjà
que ça va mal finir
ces gens passionnément
dans le jeu on sait que ça va mal finir
moi j'aime bien cette idée d'
enthousiasme liées à la notion de talent
on a tous un talent particulier au moins
on le découvre au moment où elle exprime
on se retrouve une certaine joie je
voulais rajouter aussi qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui peuvent pas culpabiliser
mais complexé ne pas avoir de passion
c'est un truc chiant c'est les jeunes
qui qui revient c'est le côté baba moi
j'ai pas de passion sous-entendu il ya
un espèce de rabaissement de confiance
en soi parce qu'on aura pas de passion
c'est pas un truc qui forcément déjà on
doit la voir comme ça comme un
claquement de doigts et sas créée sas
créée par les rencontres par la
curiosité et voilà ne surtout pas
culpabiliser de pas avoir de passion
parce que peut-être qu'on en a une mais
on l'a pas conscientiser et que ça peut
être n'importe quoi
ça doit pas être la passion qui est en
vogue actuelle où la passion que mes
parents veulent absolument que j'ai etc
etc
ça peut être ça va se décanter voilà jeu
pour ajouter quelques zéros complet que
ça par passion
maintenant c'est c'est très épanouissant
c'est ce qui peut nous définir sur le
long terme dans une vie une passion mais
no stress si elle n'est pas décidé et
totalement si elle n'a pas lé pa en
éclosion quand on est jeune si on prend
la réflexion de dernière werber on peut
dès lors admettre qu'une vie sans
passion c'est possible mais pas une vie
sans enthousiasme et ses différents moi
j'aime beaucoup ce parallèle en prenant
le substantif passion pour nommer un
centre d'intérêt que nous fait vibrer on
idéalise complètement le fait d'en avoir
une
mais l'état que l'on appelle passion est
un état tellement fort qui peut dominer
le mental ans a nommé un centre
d'intérêt par le mot passion était
peut-être un mauvais choix linguistique
tout simplement les beaux ils ont un
sens ils renvoient à des images et à des
schémas de pensée qui fonctionne malgré
nous dans notre cerveau un mot plus
neutre peut être un néologisme eu un mot
plus doux comme le mot joie ou
enthousiasme donc serait peut être moins
oppressant - complexant qu'on est à la
recherche de son propre alignement et de
ses propres centres d'intérêts
même si c'est ma passion d'avoir la
vidéo finale c'est pas un moment où je
vais être souriante devant mon
ordinateur comme ça
j'adore ces rushes c'est incroyable j'ai
vraiment 20 heures de rush
on va regarder ça dans la joie et la
bonne humeur non y'a vraiment des phases
où c'est compliqué c'est dur et
j'imagine que appareils comme les
passionnés de sport il ya des moments où
pas physiquement c'est fatigant c'est
éprouvant mais on lâche rien parce qu'on
veut aller jusqu'au bout et même si on
peut prendre l'exemple du sport avec les
compétitions mais ça doit être très
pesant et
et tu es dur psychologiquement d'aller
en compétition voir perdre mais tu le
fais quand même parce que tu peux pas
t'empêcher je crois à l' enthousiasme
racines à savoir qu'on a une sorte de
base d'intérêts pour quelque chose à
partir de cette racine on va construire
un tronc et des branches
moi je sais que cette passion pour les
histoires cette passion pour la
fabrication de monde m'a amené à voyager
m'a amené à m'intéresser à l'histoire
aux civilisations mais amenés à jouer à
plein de jeux de stratégie et j'ai tout
construit autour de de ce premier
intérêt étincelles on va dire je passe
par exemple à côté d'autres passions qui
aurait pu me toucher comme variable
piloté des avions
j'ai entièrement rater ce rendez-vous ou
jouer de la musique je joue très bien la
musique mais je n'ai pas travaillé
donc c'est un talent qui peu à peu a
disparu je pense parce qu'une passion 60
retiens le fait que tous les jours de 8h
à 12h30 j'écrive des histoires ça n'a
fait que renforcer mon plaisir et à les
écrire et à les lire je crois à la
régularité en progression c'est à dire
une fois qu'on a trouvé une passion il
faut pas ça devienne une routine
il faut qu'on essaie tout le temps
d'aller un peu plus loin dans mon
travail d'écrivain j'essaie tout le
temps d'atteindre une sorte de
perfection selon mes critères qui
consiste à faire des mondes dans
lesquels dès qu'on commence à mettre un
doigt dedans on est aspiré les monde
aspirant des mondes des romans univers
dans lequel ou d'un moment on oublie le
réel pour être dans cet univers c'est
intéressant la passion qui s'entretient
l'entousiasme racines
plus nous avançons et plus comprends moi
aussi qu'une passion doit être
entretenue que le fait d'être
enthousiaste ne veut pas dire qu'il ne
faut pas mettre de volonté de dents en
fait on utilise notre passion au
quotidien et on a mis à profit notre
passion pour gagner notre vie mais en
tout cas pour nous épanouir audience que
travail 75% du temps et en fait quand tu
arrives à exploiter ta passion à bon
escient
tu réponds je pense à ta question
intérieure et c'est été plus apaisée
quoi alors ça guérit pas tous les tous
les maux de la terre d'avoir une passion
mais en vrai ça soulage vachement il
passion vient donc ajouter quelque chose
ou soulager quelque chose dans nos vies
ce qui veut donc dire que l'on peut
vivre sans passion mais pas sans
enthousiasme nous sommes forcément
enthousiasmé par des moments de notre
vie c'est le fait ensuite de sortir de
sa zone de confort ou tout simplement de
construire de la régularité dans
l'expression de notre passion qu'il
intègre à nos vies et lui donne de
l'importance dans ses effets et si
j'analyse tout ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui
j'ai le sentiment que logiquement la
passion matérialiser comme faire la
couture ou
collectionner des pin's cache quelque
chose de plus intime
alors on va creuser derrière la passion
pour voir ce qu'on peut y trouver
le point commun de toutes mes
discussions a été de voir qu'il y avait
dix ont une sorte de fondement personnel
quasiment de l'ordre de l'adn dans
toutes les passions de tous mes invités
quand je réfléchis je me dis que je suis
passionné par le mentalisme le cerveau
les castes et plein de choses comme ça
mais dans le fond ce qui me plaît
m'intéresse vraiment c'est de savoir
comment et pourquoi fonctionnent les
choses et les gens ni plus ni moins et
ça ça s'est matérialisée par le
mentalisme mais le fait d'en avoir fait
mon métier sur scène en vidéo dans mes
livres vient surtout de ma curiosité à
savoir comment on monte un spectacle
comment fonctionne une vidéo comme on la
produit
comment comment ça marche le fait
d'écrire un livre qui nous guide à l'air
donc d'être quasi génétique et si ça ne
l'est pas il y aurait fort à parier que
ça se développe le très jeune chez nous
de part des choses qu'on rencontre dans
notre vie où de par notre entourage que
je me souviens j'ai des souvenirs et à
ces jeunes vers 5-6 ans où je me dis je
veux pas faire comme les autres je veux
être original en fait j'ai souvenir à 6
ans de d'avoir des notions et des
erreurs compris l'idée d'originalité pas
ça ça casse pas trois pattes incarner se
dire ah je vois que tout le monde fait
ça moi je vais faire un petit peu
différent à l'école sur sur des petits
trucs 1 me mais proposer des idées de
jeu à la récré etc
et il y avait toujours ce ce côté
c'était assez naturel de dire je vais
aller un peu plus loin que l'idée
basique du petit jeu dans la cour et
venez on fait ça vous ne rajoute cette
petite règle et c'est çà s'est c'était
assez c'était assez en tout cas dans mes
premiers souvenirs de vie je l'est déjà
moi je ce que je sens c'est que la
passion c'est une réponse à une question
qu'on n'arrive pas à formuler pour moi
c'est moi pourquoi j'aime la musique
pourquoi j'aime chanter pourquoi j'aime
échanger avec les gens parce qu'en fait
je les analyse et il ya peu de temps
mais c'est que quand j'étais adolescente
je n'arrivais pas à exprimer ce que je
ressentais comme interdisait beaucoup de
le dire que dès que je disais quelque
chose au lycée ou au collège
rabroué que du coup j'ai créé un
mécanisme de défense dans l'humour dans
la blague et les seuls moments où je
pouvais dire ce que je voulais et où
personne n'allait contre moi c'est quand
je chantais donc en fait pour moi je dis
souvent que chanter c'est une deuxième
langue c'est peut-être nul est débile
pour certains mais moi c'est un vrai
sens et que je ne serais sûrement pas là
où je suis maintenant si je n'avais pas
eu la chance au monde
et si j'avais pas rencontrer ce canal
des changes pour pour pour moi m'apaiser
quoi et je crois qu'en fait depuis le
début de non pas que je mens mais je
crois que ce qui m'a plus grande passion
c'est d'échanger en fait c'est que en
chantant je le sens je me sens comprise
dans une forme des changes qui est
incroyable et que moi je comprends tout
à fait aidé en fait je crois que ce que
j'aime c'est le canal par lequel sa
passe les changes
moi c'est la musique mais je crois que
j'aime encore plus partager avec les
gens pètent et c'est pour ça que j'ai
fait des vidéos et c'est pour ça que
aussi je fais de l'humour et c'est pour
ça que je suis sur scène aussi en
chantant je crois que oui peut-être même
avant la musique est ma passion c'est
les gens c'est nul c'est vrai je crois
mais c'est comme tout ça reprend la
question de l'amour est ce qu'on peut
aimer plusieurs personnes est-ce que tu
auras pas une passion qui sera quand
même au dessus des autres parce que elle
elle est inconsciente elle vient de
l'enfance est elle te rappelle quelque
chose il ya un affect c'était c'était
une passion que tu partageais avec ton
père ou ton grand-père et à quel moment
il y en a quand même mule peut-être
qu'ils étaient plus fortes partager sa
passion si c'est un truc hyper
intéressant comment on peut être
sensible un truc qui nous intéresse pas
du tout au début et on rencontre un type
comme ça dans un bar qui va commencer à
nous parler de voyage d'une table en
bois et si nous raconte avec amour et
qui nous partage sa passion il ya une
connexion qui se fait ce que je m'en
fous des tables en bois mais tout d'un
coup la façon dont il va partager son
amour et où je sens que on aura un point
commun parce que moi je voulu parler de
ma passion et qu'en fait le
le simple fait que deux personnes
passionnées se parlent de leur passion
il ya quelque chose alors qu'à la base
elles sont à l'affût de l'un de l'autre
mais il ya quelque chose que west show
rooms et ainsi ils partagent aussi la
passion moi je suis un surfer douceur ou
est ce ce look de surfeur et je dis tout
le temps la vie c'est comme le surf
qu'est ce qui est beau là dedans dans le
surf vous devez remonter le tube c'est
un peu un effort mais de façon à un
moment donné vous attendez la vague il
ya la plupart des gens 80% des gens ils
sont dans la métaphore il se retourne
vers les gens y font
elle est bien la vague karim là et elle
est bien là tu croises d'apprendre cela
n'en vous l'apprenez et puis qu'est-ce
qui vous fait vous allez tomber vous
allez tomber dans l'eau mais vous vous
serez amusé c'est pas lui c'est une
notion de temps et et de difficultés et
qu'on lâche pas il ya quand même un truc
ou au fond de toi tu vibres pour ça je
crois que derrière beaucoup d
enthousiasme
il y à la compensation d'une blessure
c'est parce que j'étais pas très bon
élève à l'école parce que j'étais pas
très social que les univers fantastiques
me raconter mon père en mythologie me
toucher autant c'est parce qu'aussi gt
gt un peu solitaire à l'école que le
fait de raconter des histoires
m'apporter au temps et au fur et à
mesure que ce monde me semblait un monde
étranger et dans lequel j'aurai des
difficultés à macérer le plaisir d'être
dans des mondes artificielle avec des
règles différentes me toucher l'idée de
par exemple quand j'ai joué la
sinisation de faire le cas des
civilisations c'était en fait une
volonté de refaire un monde meilleur que
celui dans lequel je me trouvais parce
que dans ce monde gt gt pas bien je me
disais je vais essayer de faire mieux
on peut donc conclure beaucoup de choses
sur la passion déjà je suis ravi d'avoir
eu toutes ces personnes qui sont
reconnus pour ce que nous pensons être
leur passion mais qui ont dévoilé le
derrière de leurs sentiments vis-à-vis
de ça d'ailleurs avant de passer à la
suite je vais prendre 10 secondes pour
remercier tous les intervenants de cette
vidéo
les chaînes youtube de pierre cros
benjamin d'erika pas 'je le la du bini
la toux sont en lien dans la description
je vous invite à aller les voir
évidemment comme tous les mondes que
bernard werber a créé d'un celi zhu mais
également le lien
description leurs témoignages à tous ont
été précieux pour mieux comprendre la
passion ils ont parlé sans filtre d'une
partie assez intime de leur vie donc
merci à eux beaucoup merci également à
disney de m'avoir proposé ce partenariat
et de m'avoir aidé à monter ce sujet
autour de la passion et autour de
l'histoire des jo gartner je vous invite
vraiment à regarder sol où vous
découvrirez le point de vue de jo et de
22 le film d'animation est aussi cool à
regarder que fort dans les questions
qu'ils soulèvent sol est dispo depuis le
25 décembre en streaming exclusivement
sur disney de plus vous avez le lien
dans la description
en conclusion ces passions
enthousiasmante petits compromis
d'appellation se place en supplément
dans nos vies en supplément de quelque
chose elles sont souvent l'expression
des choses plus profondes chez nous et
peuvent aussi être changements ne sont
pas forcément figer un peu comme si on
pouvait utiliser des miroirs différents
pour envoyer le même reflet d'une
personne c'est peut-être pour ça que
l'on a parfois du mal à a trouvé sa
passion visible mais ça veut pas dire
pour autant qu'on n'a pas une passion
profonde plus générale plus large qui
représente un trait de caractère chez
nous ou qui représente simplement une
envie ou un but les passions qui sont de
l'ordre de l'activité ne sont alors
durable dans le temps que si on le
décide
paradoxalement ça demande une régularité
une sorte d' efforts à fournir parfois
des compromis pour que cette occupation
devienne durable vraiment dans le temps
et qu'elle s'ancre dans nos vies et puis
il faut aussi oser découvrir de nouveaux
territoires au sens figuré dans nos vies
pour rencontrer ce qui va nous
enthousiasmer vraiment alors soyez
curieux soyez curieux parce qu'au final
exprimé qu'ils ont menée au travers
d'une passion ça changera pas le monde
mais ça transformera peut être le vôtre
à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]